[Music]
what's up Wolfgang we have 18 days until
Avengers infinity war comes out it's
getting real
yesterday it was super awesome because
we got a clip of Thanos wielding the
Infinity Gauntlet with 4 Infinity stones
in it I did a video on this yesterday in
which I said I thought that the stones
inside of the Infinity Gauntlet where
the Power Stone the space stone the
reality stone and the mine stone as
always I asked you guys to leave your
comments and thoughts below and you did
some of you mentioned that you did not
think that it was the mine stone inside
the government but in fact it was the
soul stone this is why I asked you guys
to comment below because I do appreciate
your comments and I do appreciate the
interaction and hey we're all here
because we're super excited for Avengers
infinity war and we love Marvel and I
really appreciate your interaction so
today I'm going to do a video on if that
is indeed the soul stone how a knows got
it as always these theories could
contain some spoilers about Avengers
infinity war so if you don't want to
hear any now's your chance to turn away
also be sure to hit that subscribe
button to stay up-to-date on Avengers
infinity war I promise it won't hurt so
to start off I'm going to talk about why
I actually don't think it's the soul
stone my main reasoning behind this is I
just don't think that the Russo brothers
would divulge the soul stone just so
casually in a trailer there's been so
many theories and rumors and
speculations about the soul stone
there's a lot of hype around it right
now and I just don't think that the
Russo brothers would go hey here here's
the soul stone right in the gauntlet and
yes I do realize that it looks very
orange inside of the gauntlet but if you
look in a few scenes that are given to
us in the trailers sometimes the stone
inside visions head looks orange I also
realized that the Russo brothers
basically told us that the mind stone
will be in the center of the gauntlet
however I kind of think that the Russo
brothers may be trolling us a little bit
just trying to keep everything a secret
the mine stone doesn't have to go in the
middle for example in one of the comics
the time stone is actually in the middle
these are just a few reasons why I think
it's actually the mind stone that's
inside of the Infinity Gauntlet in this
scene but however I realize that it very
well could be the
soulstone it is very orange and
technically it's in the right place and
the Infinity Gauntlet so how does
Stannis get it well there is the theory
that he's already had it this whole
entire time this could be danos already
had the mine stone before he gave it to
loki in which case loki lost it so he's
had Infinity stones before but I don't
think it's likely because I think we
would have already seen it by now with
the exception of the clip that this
trailer is taken from that we saw just a
few days ago
it doesn't appear in any other trailers
and the Infinity Gauntlet
then there's the theory that you have to
sacrifice a soul in order to obtain the
soul stone when you sacrifice a soul
that soul then gets trapped inside the
stone in what is known as soul world
many have been trapped in Soul world in
the comics including Gamora Krypton owes
have sacrificed Gamora to retrieve the
soul stone this is very possible because
there is a rumor going around that the
soul you sacrifice you have to care very
deeply about in order to obtain the soul
stone as far as I'm concerned the only
person that Thanos could really care
about besides death is Gamora his
adopted daughter this next theory is
technically the same theory but instead
of Gamora being the one that sacrificed
people think it's Tony many people
believe that this scene is actually Tony
trapped in Soul world not Titan and this
scene you can tell that Tony just looks
like he's lost all hope and it could be
because Diana's put him into Soul world
we also have the scene of Thanos on
Titan saying I hope they remember you he
could be talking to Tony right before he
sends him to soul world another theory
is that nanos actually uses the reality
stone to go and retrieve the soul stone
this could be true perhaps the reason we
haven't actually seen the soul stone is
because it's in a different reality or
dimension or universe perhaps Thanos
knew where it was the whole entire time
and once he got the reality stone he
just simply went and got it and the last
theory I'll talk about is the theory
that states that somehow Captain America
has the soul stone this theory comes
from the fact that in one of the
trailers we see Captain America
resisting Thanos when Thanos has two
Infinity stones and his Infinity
Gauntlet it's possible we know captain
strong but he's not that strong to be
able to resist Thanos with the Infinity
Gauntlet on and two Infinity stones in
it yet he does does this power perhaps
come from him hold
the soul stone I don't believe so
personally especially in the MCU how
really no human can hold an infinity
stone without dying but people seem to
think that there's this glow in his eyes
that's kind of orange that reflects him
having the soul stone and the fact that
he can resist Thanos I really don't
think this is the case but then again
the Russo brothers said that us as fans
have no idea what the plot of Avengers
infinity war is so anything's possible
these are just a few of the theories out
there of how channels could get his
hands on the soul stone do you guys
think one of these theories is right do
you guys think another theory out there
is right or do you have a theory of your
own let me know in the comments below I
love to hear from you guys and I love
interacting with you in the comment
section also don't forget to like this
video and hit that subscribe button to
join the wolf gang and stay up to date
with Avengers infinity war Marvel and
all things superhero thank you so much
for watching woof woof
[Music]
you